thank you mr speaker with permission
i'll update the house on the
government's response to events at home
and abroad during the easter recess
i will come to ukraine in a moment since
i've just left a virtual meeting with
president biden
president macron chancellor schultz and
eight other
world leaders but let me
begin
in all humility by saying
that on the 12th of april
i received a fixed penalty notice
relating to an event in downing street
on the 19th of june 2020
i paid the fine
immediately
and i offered the british people a full
apology and i take this opportunity
on the first available sitting day
to repeat my wholehearted apology to the
house
[Music]
as soon as i received the notice
acknowledge the hurt
and the anger
and i said that people had a right
to expect better
of their
prime minister
and i repeat that mr speaker again
in the house now
let me also say
not by way
of mitigation
or excuse
but purely purely because it explains my
previous words in this house
that it did not occur to me then
or subsequently
that a gathering in the cabinet room
just before a vital meeting on covid
strategy could amount
to a breach of the rules
i repeat
that was my
mistake
and i apologize for it
unreservedly
i respect the outcome of the police
investigation
which is still
underway
and i can only say that i will respect
their decision-making and always take
the appropriate steps and as the house
will know i have already taken
significant steps to change the way
things work in number 10.
and it is precisely because i know
that so many people are angry
and disappointed
that i feel an even greater sense of
obligation
to deliver
on the priorities of the british people
and to respond in the best traditions of
our country
to putin's barbaric onslaught against
ukraine
our ukrainian friends are fighting for
the life of their nation
and they achieved the greatest feat of
arms of the 21st century by repelling
the russian assault on kiev
and the whole house will share my
admiration for their heroism and courage
putin arrogantly assumed that he would
capture kiev in a matter of days
and now the blackened carcasses
of his tanks and heavy armor litter the
approaches to the capital on both banks
of the denipa
and are smoldering monuments
to his failure
having pulverized the invaders armored
spearheads the ukrainians then
counter-attacked and by the 6th of april
putin had been compelled to withdraw his
forces from the entire kiev region
britain and our allies supplied some of
the weaponry
but it was ukrainian valor and sacrifice
which saved their capital
i traveled to kiev myself
on the 9th of april
the first g7 leader to visit since the
invasion and i spent
four hours
with president vladimir zelensky
the indomitable leader of a nation
fighting for survival who gives the roar
of a lion-hearted people
i assured him of the implacable resolve
of the united kingdom
shared across this house
to join with our allies
and give his brave people the weapons
they need to defend themselves
when the president and i went for an
impromptu walk through central kiev uh
we happened upon a man who immediately
expressed his love uh for britain and
the british people and he was generous
enough to say quite unprompted i should
reassure the house i will tell my
children and grandchildren
they must always remember that britain
helped us
but the urgency is even greater now
because putin has
regrouped his forces and launched a new
offensive in the donbass we knew
this danger would come
and when i welcomed president duder of
poland to downing street on the 7th of
april and chancellor schultz the
following day we discussed exactly how
we could provide the arms that ukraine
would desperately need to counter
putin's next onslaught
on the 12th of april i spoke to
president biden to brief him on my visit
to kiev and how we will intensify our
support for president zielinski and i
propose that our long-term goal must be
to strengthen and fortify ukraine to the
point where russia will never dare
to invade again
just as our foreign policy must look to
the long term the same is true of this
government's domestic priorities
and as we face the economic aftershocks
of kovid and the consequences of russian
aggression that is above all in tackling
the impact on british energy prices and
on consumers and on family bills and
that's why we're spending over nine
billion pounds to help families
struggling with their bills we're
helping families to insulate their homes
and reduce costs and to end our
dependence on putin's oil and gas
and to ensure that energy is cheaper in
the long term we publish on the 7th of
april a new strategy to make british
energy greener more affordable and more
secure
we will massively expand offshore wind
and in the country that split the atom
we will build a new reactor not every
decade but every year this government is
joining with our allies to face down
putin's aggression abroad while
addressing the toughest problems at home
helping millions of families with the
cost of living making our streets safer
and funding the nhs to clear the cobit
backlog
my job is to work every day to make the
british people
safer more secure and more prosperous
and that is what i will continue to do
and i commend this statement to the
house